hi my name is Mike LaRon I'm an engineer
on the Android development team Android
is an open software platform for mobile
development it is intended to be a
complete stack that includes everything
from the operating system through
middleware and up through applications
now I'm going to focus in detail on a
few of the api's that I think provide
fertile ground for innovation the first
is the location manager this is a set of
API that allows you to get geographic
information it will let you find out
your current location and it will also
let you register to receive
notifications if you get close to
something interesting so you can
actually register you can register an
intent with the location manager that
will be fired when you get close to a
point that you specify and that lets you
do things like be notified when you get
close to one of your friends or it lets
you be notified when you get close to
say an ice cream shop that has
particularly good ice cream in it that's
kind of interesting innovative
application this kind of API enables the
location manager will use GPS if the
device comes equipped with GPS if it
doesn't it will make do with whatever
information is available that might be
getting information from cell tower IDs
or if there's a Wi-Fi network that has
geographic location information in it
will use that information to try to at
least narrow down where you are while
building applications for the Android
platform we found that it was useful to
have an always-on data connection so
that the server can send notifications
to the two devices running the Android
platform it turned out this is such a
useful piece of infrastructure that we
decided to package it up and make it
available as part of the public
framework and that has been done by
creating the XMPP service api's the XMPP
service allows any application to send
device to device data messages to any
user who's running Android on their
device now that data can be whatever
information makes sense for the
application so for a multiplayer game
that might be that I've moved my knight
to a particular location or whatever
makes sense for the game but it could
also be something else
geographic information so with
appropriate permissions and security the
user could send their location to their
buddies so that their buddies could
actually see where they are at any given
time and plot that information on a map
again this works with any gmail account
so any application can send this type of
peer-to-peer messages without having to
build any server infrastructure the next
API is one of my favorites it's called
the notification manager and it allows
any application to put a notification
into the status bar we use the status
bar for things like SMS notifications
voicemail notifications all of the
typical things you'd expect to see on a
phone however we make that same facility
available to any application and so that
means that developers can have the same
power to alert the user to interesting
events as what have traditionally been
built in applications this has a lot of
benefits first it means that all
notifications have a consistent
presentation now the way we do it in the
UI we have a visible preview of what the
notification means so if an icon appears
in the status bar you can click on it or
touch it to make it active so you can
see a preview of what it means which
means you don't have to figure out what
each of 30 different hieroglyphics means
then if you want to act on that
notification you can simply touch on it
and you will be taken to whatever
application is responsible for that
notification this allows a lot of really
interesting scenarios it means that
applications can notify you of things
like when an auction is ending or if
someone has invited you to be their
friend on a social network or if a bus
is coming and all of those notifications
can have the same level of prominence in
the UI as something like voicemail or
the other built-in notifications and
finally I'd like to take a minute to
talk about the view system in Android
Android provides a really rich toolkit
of built-in views and you can use those
to assemble your applications out of
standard parts so we provide things like
a ListView and a grid view a gallery
view we provide all the standard widgets
like buttons and check boxes and by
combining those things you can build
your application
really quickly we've also done a lot of
work in the framework to support
multiple input methods and multiple
screen sizes and multiple keyboard
configurations in the view system itself
so that you don't have to worry about
that in your application so for example
our list views work with touch but they
also work if you want to drive them with
a five-way d-pad and that's just a
built-in facility of the view framework
in addition to that sort of views
we also are introducing two really
innovative views the first is a map view
this is an actual this is an
implementation of the same map rendering
engine that's in our Maps application
but we decided to make that available as
a view so that applications can have
really tight really tight integration
with geographic data so it's of course
possible to always launch the map
application to display a particular
location but what the maps view let you
do is actually embed a map view in your
application so that you can control it
from your own code so you can set it to
a particular location zoom in zoom out
pan the map control all of that from
your own code to build whatever kind of
application you want to build based on
that we've done something similar with
the browser there's a browser
application that you can launch to
display a web page but we also have a
webview that enables you to embed HTML
content as a view in your application
that you can then fill with whatever
data makes sense for your app personally
what I'm hoping to see come out of the
Android effort is the kind of innovation
that comes from what I call the mashup
effect we really had two goals in mind
when we set out to create Android the
first was to provide developers with a
powerful toolkit for building new types
of experiences this toolkit includes
things like the application framework
the view system things like the maps of
view and the web view that you can embed
in your application device to device
messaging through XMPP location sort of
services notifications and all the other
pieces of our API but the second and
more important goal was to be
sufficiently open and extensible to
allow these pieces to be combined in
ways that we really haven't imagined yet
if you're interested in finding out more
about and
I encourage you to visit the developer
site and download the SDK in the SDK
you'll find a lot more documentation and
sample code and you'll also be able to
try building applications of your own
there's also a developer group that you
can join to find out more information
and I also encourage you to check back
frequently because we'll be posting
updates to the SDK as the platform
matures thank you for watching